really buff guys are [__] absolutely
disgusting what are you doing dude what
are you doing hey guy chill out what are
you doing what do you make [__] 30
grand a year you know these guys are
like I'm competing for the ifbb PB
Pro something shouldn't be what are
those anagrams and acronyms whatever
those things are there's too many of
them too many letters done I'm Computing
for the ifpb PPP
Pro I I was a winner of the [__] I
PBF PBF Pro in Utah SLC I PBF PP SLC
Utah USA
PBO it's too much dude you hey also
you're
short dude the people every you look at
up all the people who are bodybuilders
are like 5'9 and 5'8 and [__] and it's
like just chill hey e you're short if
you're really big in a bodybuilder
here's the other thing thing you're
going to die soon if you're really big
and you're going to be a bodybuilder if
you're like six 65 you're going to die
soon
dude you know work out a healthy amount
eat enough chicken here we go
musclemania here we go chw soon at the
16 musclemania University show Universe
show idiot so he's he's posing these
guys look absolutely terrible like it
doesn't look good what the
[__]
so not natural everyone's doing steroids
you know and why do they pretend like
they're
not little as penises too and not
because they're necessarily little but
because the muscles are so big it makes
it look and this is all let me just so
okay before we even really get into this
video the worst thing is being this buff
okay the second worst thing honestly I
think the two there's two worst things
in the world
that uh in the category
of uh
so hard to do and so hard to achieve and
matters the least okay being extra buff
number one number two and I've always
said this break dancing dude you're so
it's so hard you've so many
years so many years
training you know not taking away from
how much dedication you have that's why
all these bodybuilders talk about
dedication because it's all they
have I'm So Dedicated dude I'm [__]
dedicated yeah all right cool for what
now you're bigger okay also you're
like 30 lbs bigger it's not that much
you know or you're or you're you you
lost fat so and every time I talk about
this people are like all right bro
you're a [__] hater you're a
beta I I work out so I'm I'm not
like I'm not upset about any of this
[__] it's just bodybuilding and also
break dancing and I believe this video
is
both
no doesn't he do both
whatever it
is so insecure this guy oh oh oh oh oh
doesn't know what to do it starts
dancing his muscles are fantastic dude
so insecure this looks like AI this
straight up looks like AI the worst
routine God he's so muscular dude chw
soon oh bodybuilding yeah
yeah dude he's break dancing a little
bit bro
that's so
dumb the guy works so hard at the most
things that don't matter I love
it the head thing is great this head
swivel thing unreal uh so
anyway I don't know I'm
Natty took [__] cre [__] for four
days probably stopped doing that but
that's Natty
dude right it's Natty I don't know my my
friend was talking about how he knew
somebody on trt and he's just like so
strong and I'm like that's cool but then
synthetically you'll make trt and then
your body won't you you'll make
testosterone and then your body won't
make testosterone naturally so that's
great that's cool and so it's like you
got to keep taking it and I guess that's
okay if you keep taking it but
also now you got to keep taking that
[__] drug it's like me
and shal pram uh anyway switching meds
though too many [__] thoughts in my
head M by the way do you know what
palumboism is it's when your your
stomach you're so Juiced that your
stomach is distended and it's popping
out and it's and I was like why is it
called Palumbo palumboism because the
first guy on record to get it was named
somebody Palumbo and I'm like oh dude
worst like at least luk Garrick's
disease can like kill you palumboism you
just kind of look like dolls them you
know and that's so gross I
think working out is cool